hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
we're gonna continue Cobra Kai over here
we can only show ten minutes of the
YouTube cut for you guys because
otherwise it'll get blocked but Oh Brock
our patreon we actually do full-length
TV show watch along for you guys over
there
I personally cover attack on Titan did
all of the flash season for home most of
and I also cover Gotham just started
that up
John covers Riverdale just started up
channel zero he did most of Atlanta he
covers Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
add together we cover my Cobra my
Kubrick and together we covered Cobra
Kai my hero academia Jessica Jones
season two and one more episode of black
lightning which we must finish and
plenty of other goodies as well so go
check out our patreon would love to have
you become a great supporter of the
channel anyway let's watch the train
hard gotten stronger tougher faster
you've done your best you're ready for
this tournament am i right give me a
beer
[Music]
[Music]
oh goody sorrow
[Music]
I said we get the car back you know I
could find out where he lives
Cobra Kai will never change promise me
you stay away from the kids were
associated with she might be letting one
of them inside you're our man
[Music]
save some for the tournament why am I
the only one here since they stole let's
face it
I'm your best student have you seen the
others We Need to Talk it's gonna the
summaries that make a sex tape rocky
three years now right just come to mr. t
fancy a Valentine's dinner rings I gave
her this pink jelly bracelet
that tied her up she gave me this we got
into a fight I figured we work things
out eventually I got more points than
her they manually Rousseau gave me to
them that's a great da geing technology
seriously Joseph expects to see that you
don't flirting with each other I don't
know where guys sucker punch
I did what any dude we do I defended
myself that was that yeah sitting there
minding my own business
Gauss's being at the water hose
eventually we decided to work these out
of the oven
way later disease what's worse as I lost
a li is it no don't tell later this is
like when children of gangsters fall
[Laughter]
together
it's for getting to work which he had
done several times
this is interfering with our business so
just stay out of it oh very nice
oh they gonna do it
you can survive they gonna do this sexy
I could snap with my lotion fingers I
would or you or the TV sex whisper me
that's what my friends I could listen to
Spanish all day Miguel told me all about
the tournament mmm candy really like
he's bananas no plantains English we
call them so funny Johnny kind of looks
like an animated slaw just say he was a
very bad man
he almost please you - you can let the
mistakes of the past determine your
future
hey dude but the facts of your life
become the excuses for your life that's
a lesson for Johnny Lawrence right there
I'm gonna clean up she's gonna show up
he's gonna dump me go right okay get
your life in order Johnny clean I've
never seen a woman before about you and
I should thank you good luck with the
tree Bobby she was flirting it she hates
Miguel night dream is a good place to
meditate Yeah right
what are you here nothing just like
Winnie the Pooh yeah hey call back he
hung that TV she's gotta come knocking
dude he could probably hook up with his
wife she's excellency
he chose the OJ over the beer they call
this stuff
[Music]
drove heavens for drum Tech where it is
done doubles lots of karate kid' shots
right here man California is a state
with a diverse topography but this
doesn't look like I mean they must not
have been ours yeah the lake anyway it
looks like you know what's gonna break
Johnny and Danny together dude Robbie's
gonna have to dad I love you that's
pretty good
gonna fall break his head rushing to the
hospital that wasn't get very dark no
watching porn
was that really him you ready for the
next challenge what's that
hold this rock back signing the car his
best Jeff Bridges right now I never
needed your money it's just the only
thing you had to give Oh take some of
that smoked salmon with you man
Johnny's growing up Miguel's gonna show
up when Robby is there Oh God oh my god
it's happening you you have a very
finely tuned compass for on-screen
romance realize just how much right fast
but my biggest screwup it is my
relationship with you this will teach
that piece of [ __ ] not to mess with my
family you're doing consider this a
message from Daniel Larusso oh yeah you
are
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Miguel's gonna hate freakin Samantha for
view oh my gosh this is so bad alright
alright you can't
we got a kill we gotta kill the brother
we got to get inside the show we have to
wait a couple episodes left but damn
dude that is a cliffhanger right there
that's easily the most intense the show
it's cotton
yeah I've wondered what Danny's brother
like just as a joke almost if he's got
any sort of more sinister dealings yeah
but like the fact that he did that
suggests that his characters at least
probably involved in some Monica Hades
is problematic man he's a problematic
dude and actually like how the element
played in and of course you would say
the message for Daniel is you just make
the whole thing whole thing worse than
like man it's all building up to the
worst possible scenario
never trust a mostly heartwarming
episode yeah because it's like
everything seemed to be arcing in the
right direction for Johnny for once like
oh he's kicking the alcohol easy dad
back pain a stepdad back like
everything's going down the right path
for him dinner Hilary is car as baby
gets torched and it thinks Danny Larusso
set him up to this and when Miguel going
to the house seemed Robbie there it's
funny how like some things are working
out good for them which are causing
negative effects for the other
characters vice-versa on
spectrum of this because Robbie's whole
journey was like really delightful
really a heartfelt it's cool that he's
getting good at it but I'm wondering
what's gonna become once because Danny's
obviously gonna learn about Robbie being
Johnny's kid which is gonna know the
whole thing in the chaotic yeah it
seemed like they were teasing that the
attitudes of some of the Cobra Kai
students are gonna become a negative
effect Mohawk yeah popcorn he's like a
big alpha male yeah so it's making me
wonder is McGill gonna retaliate is
Miguel gonna take on a more negative
mean persona
especially since Johnny started off the
episode with going you gotta be careful
of the larusso's so is he gonna lash out
at Samantha now even though she was
doing nothing wrong but she does seem
like she's kind of flirting with him
this is intense this is the first time
like this show is intense - like all the
things we've worked for and they they
start off this episode by touching on
the idea can Cobra Kai change yeah and I
feel like that's something that they are
gonna have to prove because I could see
yeah exactly now at this point Cobra Kai
becoming very much the old Cobra Kai if
things don't persist in the right
direction and if some of these bigger
better lessons that have been coming up
in recent episodes don't stick well even
though no one's a bad guy here except
for Danny's cousin I'll take my looks
like a man yeah when it comes to this
episode though it just really looks like
the larusso's are the bad guys she's not
willing to admit she has a boyfriend
because she's afraid because he's in
Cobra Kai so he shows up there's another
dude there who's Robbie and that makes
Danny look bad cuz that's Johnny's kid
and then but message from Danny Larusso
everything looks bad on the Larusso side
which is elevating that Cobra Kai is
alright you know like this is so chaotic
and I was not expecting the suspense and
twist is there was one comment that came
in on a previous episode go and you guys
better hurry up before someone ruins the
show for you and I'm like well I don't
really know what like really twister
wanna turn reveals I could really land
into like Oh majors but I'm so ruined
that yeah sure okay gotta avoid comments
now on all these episodes because I
don't want anything ruined for me
because that was really impactful they
didn't see that coming at all and they
set it up at the beginning of the
episode really
well two for something to be a really
negative consequence for everyone in the
end that was great yeah like the points
of tension I thought they built those
really well and also the things that
we're rewarding were super rewarding I
thought this was a very multifaceted
episode because you get to watch some
actual good progress happened to just as
much as there are alarming things it is
heartwarming to watch Danny and Robbie
train together yeah like the enrichment
that's coming Johnny welcome into
McGill's home for dinner and everything
like that was really nice too there's a
lot of heartwarming stuff in here but
the tensions is the big takeaway yeah
all be for naught yeah it's like I
thought that moment where Robbie's
almost gonna tell Danny about his dad
was bad enough yeah yeah we oh boy can't
wait can't wait to continue this show
thanks guys for encouraging us to watch
it cuz there's one hell of an amazing
we're gonna call the take it in a couple
minutes now so we gotta wrap this up
anyway guys like I said full-length TV
show reaction watch Long's are all on
our patreon for many shows including
Cobra Kai you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
about the subscribe buttons don't really
work ad yeah check us on social media
all that